when I was 21 years old I wanted to be
an entrepreneur I did an extensive
amount of research on how to open a
frozen yogurt store they on average make
between 750 and 800 000 a year I thought
800 000 a year that means I make 800 000
a year I'm Gonna Be Rich doesn't really
work that way the average store that
we're talking about does 2 000 plus
dollars a day they run margins between
10 and 15 percent the average Menchie's
owner for context makes ninety three
thousand dollars a year take home most
franchises have six percent ish of top
line that goes straight to them that may
not sound like much but if you're
running 10 margin that's 60 percent of
your take home and what most people
don't know is that franchises will
structure their fees so you make just
enough that you can keep going and maybe
if you're a good operator open another
location but not so much that you're
going to get rich on it so they're only
looking to optimize to beat the return
on capital of the stock market by a
decent amount if the stock market gets
you 10 they're going to try and get 20
to 25 and they're going to squeeze off
the top and take the rest because of how
good their model is